und jetzt meine damen und herren wollen
wir ihnen eine video zeigen dass gerade
für große aufregung sorgt bevor wir uns
das anschauen erklärt uns unsere
chefreporterin antonia jamin die hier
bei mir im studio ist was genau es damit
auf sich hat es handelt sich um ein flug
401 der letzte woche von jeff pain new
york nach frankfurt fliegt an bord auch
stur der lufthansa-flug ein lufthansa
flug auf der maschine auch passagiere
eine handvoll von passagiere die einfach
keinen bock hat eine maske anzuziehen
haben natürlich auch vor stress dann bei
der stadt essen gesorgt auch an bord 150
jüdische ultraorthodoxe passagiere die
eigentlich den plan hatten von new york
nach frankfurt zu fliegen und dann
weiter nach budapest
aber als sie dann in frankfurt ankamen
erwartete sie eine überraschung nämlich
polizeikräfte mit gewehr und die meldung
ihr alle durften nicht mitfliegen warum
konnte keiner sagen außer eine studentin
und ihre antwort war wirklich
schockierend und jetzt haben wir uns die
jetzt mal an
warum darf ich nicht mitfliegen
alle müssen für den fehler von einem
zahlen also jeder der jüdisch aussieht
einige durften herr weiterfliegen
nicht jeder wird die nichtjuden durften
weiter also weshalb müssen nur jüdische
passagiere für die fehler anderer zahlen
weil es juden sind sie mit dem flugzeug
aus new york gekommen sind weil sie
juden waren die für das durcheinander
gesorgt haben die haben die probleme
gemacht also einige juden haben probleme
gemacht und deshalb werden alle juroren
vom flug ausgeschlossen nur für diesen
bist selbst jüdin deutsch israel in
jetzt könne man frage war das jetzt
einfach dämlichkeit ungeschick der
lufthansa oder ist dass antisemitismus
was wir gesehen haben also ich meine
wenn du diese äußerung von der steuer
dessen horst gibt es da denke ich mal
kaum raum zur zweifel muss dir
vorstellen dass plötzlich ein mensch der
eine ganze gruppe gehört plötzlich
versteht dass er nicht weiter fliegen
kann die ultraorthodoxen sind leicht zu
erkennen die tragen halt schwarze mäntel
auch diesen schwarzen hut und tu dir
einfach vorstellen mal dass es nicht um
juden geht sondern um schwarze
passagiere gibt wird sich nicht alle
schwarze passagiere auf einem flug dürfe
nicht weiter fliegen dann hätten wir es
doch auch rassismus genannt und hier
bevor stehe ich auch dass es irgendwas
mit antisemitismus zu tun hat dann
sprechen wir jetzt mal mit dem mann der
das video aufgenommen hat der genau
diese situation erlebt hat sie hält
liste uns jetzt aus new york
zugeschaltet
guten abend herr helfern erzählen sie
uns doch noch mal aus ihrer perspektive
wie das dort abliefen liebling müsste
hertha ließ baute tore gern vom lospech
tv-debatten abend danke dass ich hier
eingeladen bin
wir sind von gfk new york geflogen
ein netter fluorid und wir hatten circa
jüdische
passagiere auf dem flug und 149 von
denen haben eine maske getragen eine
person hat keine maske getragen
das hat zu problemen geführt
als wir in deutschland angekommen sind
gab es offensichtlich beschwerden
und da kamen auf einmal 25
polizeibeamtinnen und beamten in voller
montur und
ich muss sagen
dass meine großeltern aus europa
gekommen sind
entschuldigung
zum ersten mal in meinem leben jetzt in
deutschland zu landen das war etwas
außergewöhnliches und das schaue ich mir
dieses deutschland an
und ich hatte nur diese gelegenheit in
deutschland für ein paar stunden zu
bleiben ich habe es auch erwartet ich
kann mich daran erinnert wie meine
großmutter auch von ihren ängsten
erzählt hat deshalb war es für mich auch
ein bisschen erschreckend und als wir
dann deutschland nicht verlassen durften
das war traumatisch
und als uns gesagt wurde dass das
boarding uns untersagt wurde
dann
tatsächlich
den menschen gesagt die den flug nicht
betreten durften und dann haben wir
angefangen zu fragen warum wie es dazu
gekommen ist und dann hieß es es gab
probleme weil jemand die meisten tragen
haben
als ich dann mit der aufsicht gesprochen
habe und erklärt habe wir haben ja die
masken getragen warum wird uns der
zutritt nicht
erlaubt es gibt viele menschen die maske
getragen haben das kann dann auch im
video sehen
dann hieß es
jüdische menschen habt hier dieses haus
kreiert und alle müssen jetzt hier
bleiben
ist eine aussage die ich nie in meinem
leben so gehört habe und in deutschland
habe ich es natürlich auch nie erwartet
so was zu hören ich wollte sie fragen
wie wusste denn eigentlich lufthansa wer
von den passagiere jude ist und wer eben
nicht
es ist eine sehr gute frage
sie nahmen sie aufgerufen wurden unter
diesem namen für die menschen die den
flug betreten durften da gab es einige
jüdische namen aber wir waren
entsprechend gekleidet
und die menschen die entsprechend
gekleidet waren durften den flug nicht
betreten es gab auch jemanden der unter
medizinischen konditionen gelitten hat
die dürfen auch den flug lich betreten
wir haben nach wasser gefragt
und wir haben kein wasser bekommen
und es gab auch menschen die
medizinische ausstattung nach budapest
bringen wollten denen wurde es auch
nicht erlaubt den flug anzutreten und
deshalb tatsächlich 24 stunden gedauert
manche sind nach hause gefahren was
haben sie in dieser zeit gemacht
wir mussten
deutschland nicht 24 stunden
wir mussten uns in deutschland nicht 24
stunden lang aufhalten es war sehr
unbequem es hat sich nicht gut angefühlt
wir haben auch tatsächlich nichts getan
wir wurden nicht laut wir sind auch
nicht gewalttätig aber
es ging uns nicht gut das heißt darauf
unsere eigenen kosten haben wir weitere
flüge gebucht
persönlich wenn dann über wien geflogen
ist das waren circa 800 dollar pro
ticket wir haben uns für andere
fluggesellschaften entschieden sie haben
selber gesagt das war jetzt das erste
mal dass sie in deutschland fahren
werden sie wiederkommen nach dem was sie
hier erlebt haben
in germany to come again after what to
face
ich habe keinen hass in meinem herzen
niemandem gegenüber aber das war eine
schreckliche ganz schreckliche erfahrung
und ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
ich bin mir sicher dass er tolle
menschen seien aber
die lufthansa hat den jüdischen menschen
aus den usa die mehrere tausend
kilometer hinterlegt habe nur mehr
hinzukommen keinen guten eindruck
gemacht
sollte er mich einladen dann vielleicht
ja vielen dank herr helfern danke dass
sie mit uns gesprochen haben danke danke
danke
danke an euch alle und natürlich haben
wir auch lufthansa um eine stellungnahme
gebeten antonia wie war die antwort
bisher also lufthansa hat uns gegenüber
wirklich bestätigt dass sie von diesem
vorfall weiß und dass ihn auch weiterhin
recherchiert bis jetzt haben wir keine
klare antwort bekommen wie das geschehen
konnte aber wir bleiben natürlich dran
dass wir tun vielen dank antonia für den
besuch hier im studio